Washington journal continues Matt Walsh
joins us now a columnist with the blaze
he's here to talk about his new book the
unholy trinity blocking the left's
assault on life marriage and gender Matt
Walsh explain what constitutes the
unholy trinity well this book focuses on
the three battle
the three primary battlegrounds to the
culture war that's life marriage and
gender and the left has waged its
assault it's kind of three-pronged
assault to redefine human life then
marriage then gender so that's sort of
the unholy trinity that three-pronged
assault on the culture that in my
estimation is what conservatives and
Christians and anyone who's not a far
left radical should be focused on why'd
you write the book because you know for
one thing to explain these concepts you
know to to to to to battle against the
left's war to redefine these these these
kind of pillars of human civilization
but I also wanted to speak to
conservatives and and Christians and and
kind of galvanize them and unite them
around these issues because I think what
you find with on the Left they're very
United there's a united front they
understand why these issues are so
important even if they're wrong about
all of them
but on the right it seems like if you
got if you got a hundred conservatives
in a room and you ask them one of the
most important issues what are our
fundamental principles you would
probably get 75 different answers and so
that's why I wrote this this book
primarily was for conservatives and
Christians to be United around these
issues abortion is the issue you say
that sets the stage for everything else
in this book explain because abortion is
first of all we started with abortion
about 40 years ago of course and this
was the first assault where we redefined
human life and once you've redefined
human life and you've made life itself
relative because that's what you know
what is left is I'm left ISM is the
rejection of objective truth of God and
it is the kind of instituting relativism
as the guiding principle of our culture
where everything is relative to me so I
have my own true
my reality what's good for me is good
for me and so it makes sense that we
begin by making life itself relative
which is what the left has done you know
when you talk to a liberal it's not that
they'll say usually that the unborn
child is not a child all the time it's
more they say it's not a child if the
mother doesn't want it to be a child so
life itself is relative to how
convenient that life is to those around
it and once you've begun there once the
left succeeded in that area that was an
enormous amount of power and from that
kind of foundation they were able to
wage the rest of their campaign you
think the left has succeeded here well
they certainly succeeded legally they've
succeeded culturally in the sense that
you know a large preponderance of our
culture obviously are either in favor of
abortion or they don't see it as that
big of a deal you know I don't have the
statistical in front of me but if you
were if you were to you know how many
people in our culture are number one
against the killing of the unborn and
number two see it as a really big deal
which which it is you know you would
think if you do think it's killing me
unborn you would you would consider it a
pretty big deal
but I think that's a relatively small
it's a relatively small number of people
so I think the left has largely been
successful but not permanently
successful phone numbers if you want to
join this conversation with Matt Walsh
the author of the unholy trinity
Republicans it's two oh two seven four
eight eight thousand and one Democrats
202 seven four eight eight thousand
independence 202 seven four eight eight
thousand and two is your number as folks
are calling in you don't like the term
traditional marriage why because
traditional puts a qualifier on it makes
it sound like there are other forms of
legitimate marriage which there aren't
so you know I don't like traditional
marriage for the same reason I wouldn't
refer to a traditional rectangle you
know a rectangle is a rectangle a circle
is not a non-traditional rectangle it's
just not a rectangle and so with with
marriage there is there is one form of
marriage that marriage has a certain
function has certain dimensions it has a
certain purpose it does certain things
it has a certain potential has certain
responsibilities that are on it and the
the union between same-sex
whatever you call it it's not the same
thing because it does not have the same
dimensions it doesn't have the same
function doesn't have the same purpose
it doesn't have the same potential so
whatever before we even get into
assigning moral you know moral
designations are saying it's immoral or
whatever before we get into that we must
agree that it's not the same thing it is
a different thing I'm sorry of what you
just said it doesn't have the same
potential what do you mean by that it
doesn't have a life-giving potential it
there is never going to be a scenario
where two men can create a baby and in
principle the union between a man and a
woman creates a child now I know that
then the responses I'm sure people will
call in and say but what about it
infertile couple what about a couple
that you know has sterile for whatever
reason well that's you know those are
physical defects
that's not we're talking in principle
here so that's a that's a physical
defects that that's that's an aberration
that doesn't change the principle let's
let you talk with some of the caller
Sally's up first Hyattsville Maryland
line for Democrats Sally good morning
good morning um I would like to ask you
your guest how he can I'll talk about
the topics that he is using in his views
and reconcile this with Christianity
there is something about Christianity
and I am a Christian and I am a lesbian
and I am black and I am believe it or
not pro-choice but I'm also a Christian
I believe in God I believe in loving
others and I'm believing in helping
others and I don't see any Christian
trait in his comment that's all I have
to say well shall let you respond yeah
you say that you're a Christian yet
you're in favor you you think it's okay
for God's children in the womb to be
killed can you explain that she's not
here he's gone okay but that's the
intimacy what you find a lot of times on
the left is they'll come in with some
broad statement like that then they and
then they
it's just fascinating to me it's
fascinating to me that anyone could
claim to be a Christian
while not only being in favor of killing
human beings of killing innocent
children but even to say that you must
be in favor of that to be a Christian
because that's what we just heard from
the caller not just that it's okay but
that you must be you know in Jeremiah it
says before I've I formed you in the
womb I knew you
before I formed you in the womb I knew
you so how do you reconcile that with
the idea that a child could just be
killed and tossed aside I would also ask
you as a Christian how do you reconcile
the fact that Jesus Christ according to
our faith Jesus Christ came into the
world through the womb Jesus Christ was
an unborn child that's how he entered
the world so how can you say that an
unborn child is not human or as garbage
that can be tossed aside while while
Jesus Christ not only created this child
but shared in that in the same
experience was once the same thing as
the unborn child I just don't see how
you can reconcile that I think it's
crazy do you want folks on the left to
read your book yes I do do you think a
sentence like this turns them off the
first sentence of the book the first
liberal was named Lucifer yeah well if
the truth turns them off there's nothing
I can do about that if somebody is so
deluded like our last caller who
believes that Christians have an
obligation to be in favor of killing
children then as far as I'm concerned
there's nothing I can do with somebody
like that
other than just tell them the truth it's
hard for me to dance around that it's
hard for me to find a gentle way of
telling that person for instance that
they're completely wrong about
everything they think and what they
think is heretical and frankly
disgusting dennis is in West Palm Beach
Florida Republican Dennis good morning
first of all I want to thank Steve Spann
for the prior show and this one also no
one else on TV would have it I really
appreciate it I hope I don't use all my
time up with this but I'm picking up on
what Matt was just saying to the caller
that identified herself as a Christian
you know the bottom line is John the
Baptist recognized
in the womb of the Blessed Mother before
she was ever born he left in the womb is
what the Bible says when he came near
Jesus and in the Bible that also says
God says I formed I knew you when you
were in your mother's womb errs worst
about a sec I'm not a bible expert but
what I really want to get from that is
what impact does he think public schools
have on teaching our children how to
view what I'll call the culture of life
issues as opposed to the culture of
death I believe the public schools teach
them to accept the culture of death how
do the public schools teach them they
should do marriage and how do to public
schools teach our kids they should view
gender I really think that we've got to
have parental choice in the education of
our children there was a Supreme Court
case in 1925 Pierce versus versus
Society of sisters and the bottom line
is when they decided that case the
Supreme Court ruled nine and nothing in
favor of the nuns who said all children
in Oregon do not have to go to a public
school and in the Supreme Court decision
one of the key senses was where the
judges ruled nine to zero that children
are not creatures of the state that the
parents have the right to do what they
want but in like in Florida where I am
just as an example the law says all your
kids have to go to school well that's
fine you pay all your life for that you
don't get to choose to school your kids
go to unless you're wealthy and you can
pay for the public schools all your life
and then pay again to send your kids to
Catholic schools or whatever Denis got
your point in that Walsh yeah I think
you know I take a very it might not
surprise anyone that I take a very dim
view of public school system and you
know I and I know it's very difficult
because as a society we've sort of
become dependent on the public school
system which has a lot to do what has to
do with the economy a lot of people you
know you have two parents in the home
they both both have to work jobs it also
have to do with the with the collapse of
the the nuclear family where a lot of
people are dependent on the public
school essentially to parent their kids
but I think we really especially young
my parents my kids are almost four my
oldest kids are almost four so they're
not yet in you know we haven't made
these decisions yet finally about where
we're gonna send them from school but
young parents like myself I think need
to strongly consider
just abandoning the public school system
entirely and I agree with you that
obviously we need to have choice and we
need to need to do what we can to open
up these options to other people because
the public school system is completely
hostile not just to we make it clear
they're not just hostile to Christian
values which of course they are but
hostile to the truth to science even
know it's I I had a reader recently sent
me a a middle school newspaper article
from a middle school in Virginia which
was outlining all the new genders you
know there are 52 genders or whatever
they say these days and this is this is
a middle school and one of the genders
that they that they described and this
was again for kids 10 to 13 it's called
gender flux which means that you could
be partially one gender partially
another partially another you know
partially a moose or something and this
is what they're teaching in schools I
mean there's no science to this at all
there's no truth to it and I don't know
we put our kids into that system for 12
years and I don't see how they come out
with their heads still screwed on
straight Chicago Illinois
Albert Democrats good morning good
morning c-span in Jesus commanded his
disciples his followers to do two things
to love one another and to go out and
preach the gospel in love the gospel
being the message of his birth death and
resurrection he didn't command anybody
to go out and to try to interfere and
infringe upon people's god-given free
will which you all seem to enjoy doing
now there are Christians all over the
world that are being persecuted to the
point of death for actually spreading
that message of his birth death and
resurrection well you all spend your
time claiming to be persecuted and
suffering loss of your religious
liberties because there's pushback
against you all trying to but it to
other people's lives and take away their
god-given free will the Bible that Jesus
didn't command you all to butt into
people's personal lives and try to take
away their daggers we will he said to go
out and spread the message of his birth
death and resurrection not your point
Albert Matt Walsh I I don't know exactly
what specific specifically he was
referring to or in what way I've taken
away anyone's free will
it's not possible to take anyone's
freewill from them it's that that's why
it's god-given I certainly can't do it
by having opinions this is something
again you find on the left where they
are so they they are so opposed to
anyone having a different point of view
that they'll claim that just in having a
different point of view you've removed
from them the right to disagree with you
which isn't how it works that's not I'm
not a congressman I haven't made a law
saying that you're you're not allowed to
be wrong about this but let's just
because we've talked about you know
we've we've seemed to mainly talk about
abortion I can only assume he was
partially referring to that so in what
way do we respect the quote-unquote
god-given free will of an individual by
killing them in the womb Albert's still
there
you want to respond Albert Albert how do
we how do we respect someone's god-given
freewill by killing them in the womb are
you in favor of that go ahead we've lost
Albert okay well look I don't I don't
blame these callers because especially
from a Christian perspective it is
impossible to to actually defend the
notion that Christ wants us to kill our
babies it's impossible to do so all they
can do is just kind of throw out the
slogans and the talking points then run
away but I am all about respecting
god-given rights that's what I'm talking
about and on our Declaration of
Independence kind of sets the stage by
talking about what are our god-given
rights fundamentally and we begin with
we have the right to life so if you
don't have the right to life if you
can't begin by being actually being born
and having your life respected I don't
know how you get to any of these other
rights so we have to start with that and
then we can move on to these other
rights so their line for independence
Jackson Missouri patty is waiting
patty good morning good morning thank
you c-span for your for your program I
had two points to make to mr. Walsh the
first one is how our society handles its
most vulnerable such as the unborn tells
a lot about itself and I think we used
to be a great society and then of course
now it's you know perfectly legal to
just you know tell anything that you
don't happen to want and then the second
point was
I feel like a lot of the liberal they
they scream they shout they pounce and
down our throats so that they can
validate their own opinions their own I
don't know
sense points of view so I don't know I'm
not allowed to have a point of view or
maybe my own opinion or my own rights
simply because it makes them feel
uncomfortable because I'm different
therefore they have to pound it down my
my way so that they can feel better
about themselves but those are just my
two thoughts on that thank you yeah I
think you're absolutely right and going
back to your first point because I think
it's very important you know how do you
judge a society the greatness of a
society the the charity of a society how
do you really judge that and I agree
with you that you look at how do they
treat their most their absolute most
vulnerable citizens because it's easy
you know if somebody is able-bodied and
they're out there and they're working
and they're paying taxes it's easy to
respect them you know but our children
need us to take care of them and so if
we are refusing to do that not just
refusing to do it but saying we won't
even treat you like people and not only
when we not treat you like people but we
can kill you and then sell you for parts
at Planned Parenthood you know when a
society is saying that that it's hard
for me to believe that this is the you
know this is this is anything but a very
sick and frankly wicked Society no King
want you to comment on the segment of
people that believe if a woman is
pregnant due to rape that she should be
forced to give birth that's a very
obviously that you're going right to the
difficult cases and let's first
establish that ninety seven or more
percent of abortions have nothing to do
with rape or incest but if we've
established look there's only one reason
to be against abortion and that's that
the unborn child is a human being and a
person and you're not allowed to kill
innocent people
that's the only reason to be against it
if that's not the case then abortion is
okay and every in every circumstance if
that is the case then abortion is never
okay even in the really difficult
situations and what I would say in the
terrible situation where a woman is
raped and conceives a child punished the
rapist put the rapist in jail you know
life in prison I'm fine with that but
execute the child for the sins of the
father I think is a grave grave
injustice James isn't Jessup Georgia a
Republican James good morning good
morning I'm a little confused here
I seem to be a generalization about left
versus right when it comes to God if God
is a spirit that I do he dissect his
self from left versus right
generalization turn when you have the
type of partner zone always seem to be
I'd like to know who he funded back into
he have the Holy Ghost but do he believe
in the holy ghost if they're older goes
there to mentor to his accusation that
he's making this known about people in
general left versus right as to assume
all people that Republican it's so Holy
Ghost filled and all people that's left
it's all there but fear not your point
James well yeah I certainly don't think
that all Republicans are you know filled
with the holy spirit and our warriors
for truth or anything like that
in fact I began by saying that when you
look at the Republican Party or
conservatives in general there is not a
consensus on these issues and a great
many of them would agree with the left
one quote from your book the lack of
resistance from the conservative and
Christians may have been most
immediately responsible for our current
situation as it pertains to marriage the
lack of resistance the eagerness with
which many Christians seated marriage to
the homosexual lobby has its roots in
many deadly trends that infiltrated the
church in the West long ago yeah we you
know I'm all about taking the
responsibility back on ourselves and as
Christians you know we could talk about
how we've you know the culture is is so
against us and it is and so hostile to
us and all that is true but how do we
get
this point and I think we have to look
at ourselves because even now 70% of the
country is supposedly Christian I think
would call themselves Christian but if
70 percent of the country were if they
were really on fire with the faith and
they really cared about their faith and
they stood for the truth then we
wouldn't be where we are so we ended up
where we are because a lot of us either
surrendered refused to say anything or
we defected and essentially went to the
other side color want to know who you
were funded by what's your day job I
work for the blaze website and that's
that's all I'm funded by and you can
check out Matt Walsh's work at Matt
Walsh blog.com the Matt Walsh blog.com
on Twitter it's at Matt Walsh blog
David's in Conway Massachusetts
independent David good morning good
morning
hello Matt I would have to say that
religion and religious beliefs are a
highly personal thing and that we all
practice them in different ways I would
also say that I respect your right to
believe and practice your religion the
way that you wish to do so where I have
to come up and say hold on is when you
try to take your religious beliefs and
make me follow them and that is a big
issue because I'm not telling you how to
worship I'm not telling you what to
believe I'm not proposing laws that make
you do anything and yet I have lived in
a country which has laws based on
certain religions that I have to follow
even though I don't belong to that
religion how would you respond to that
sir well I don't think I'm advocating
that you should have to follow any
particular set of religious laws I'm not
saying that there should be a law that
you have to go to church on Sunday I'm
not saying there's gonna be a law that
you don't have to give up meat on on
Fridays and Lent that's not
I'm talking about that would be a
religious law but I'm talking about our
law is that that are consistent with
natural law that is the ingrained law
that's that's common to all humanity and
those are and those are things like we
all recognize that it's a it can't kill
people you can't rape those kinds of
things and that we all have a natural
human dignity so I'm talking about laws
that respect our natural human dignity
now if we're if we're if we don't have a
natural human dignity by the way then
why are we having any of these
discussions then we don't have rights at
all rights or meaningless everything's
meaningless and let's all just be
barbarians but if we do have a natural
human dignity then we do have to get to
the question of where does that come
from
and if it comes from government then
it's just a construct it's just
artificial doesn't mean anything but our
founding fathers believes that our
natural human dignity came from God and
that's why they wrote it right there in
the Declaration of Independence and
there's no other real conclusion you can
come to so our country has not founded
specifically on Christian laws where you
have to follow a kind of Christian you
know very specific theological edicts
that you find in the New Testament with
regards to things like church and that
sort of thing it's not founded on that
but it is founded on the notion that we
have natural rights endowed by God and
you can't take that out of it because
once you take God out of it then the
rights go away and and then we're back
you know to a situation where we really
where none of us have a foundation to
claim any rights whatsoever that's all
the discussing and I think and I think
that probably the caller would agree
that there should be laws against you
know burglary and theft and those kinds
of things there should be laws against
it is because we have a natural human
dignity that should be respected all I'm
talking about is extending that
principle back to the unborn when it
comes particularly to the abortion
conversation Jew that's been waiting in
San Jose California a Democrat Judith
good morning yes I have a couple of
points I'd like to make the first one is
that it seems that the Christians of
today the evangelicals want to glorify
the fertilized egg but once it's born
they want to help it out in all the
policies of the conservative agenda
they want to take away the medical care
and etc so that's going to make death
that's going to be death to babies and
Americans also if they don't want
abortions well then how come they don't
want to supply birth control to the poor
of our nation and they block that by
these are government laws that the
Conservatives make and number three is
that the ultra conservatives and
evangelicals seem to have gone along
with Trump in the in the Republicans and
they've gone around the world
overthrowing governments for ever and
ever since the Bush and Cheney went into
Iraq it's been a disaster in the Middle
East and you know they're there for that
so just a lot of topics there in about a
minute or two left Walsh I think what
you have there's a is a succession of
strongmen and deflections that
mischaracterized my argument and also
are not really related to it so let's
start with the first one the first one
is that Republicans don't care about
babies once they're born that's just
there's there's just not true that's I
don't know I don't know what Republicans
are talking to that are saying we don't
care about babies once they're born but
the real question is you know aside from
government policies because we can have
disagreements about what's the most
efficient way to take care of the poor
what's the government's proper role in
all that but the if you actually care
about the poor then what you're going to
do is you're going to go yourself to
help them you're going to donate to
charity you're going to help the poor in
an active way and I think a great vast
number of pro-lifers and conservatives
do that I do and every pro-life or
conservative I know does so that's so
that's just not true the second one was
if we don't want abortions then we have
to pay for birth control
again that's that's a what we call a
false choice why do we have to choose
between those two either give me free
birth control or I'll kill my child why
do I have to choose between those who
decided that those have to be the
choices and the third one was really
kind of amazing to me that Trump and the
Republicans are going around the world
overthrowing people
I agree the Republicans have done that
Trump hasn't done that
let me give him a chance but we just got
through eight years of Barack Obama
traipsing around the Middle East doing
regime changes you know unseating these
dictators creating a power vacuum we're
creating a void which was then filled by
largely by Isis
so Barack Obama created in a large part
him in a Hillary Clinton created this
situation in Syria and yet we're just
gonna skip over that and pretend the
last eight years didn't happen and let's
go and let's just jump right to blaming
Trump for everything I just find that
incredible and completely removed from
the facts Matt Walsh is the author of
the new book the unholy trinity blocking
the left's assault on life marriage and
gender appreciate your time this morning
thank you push it up next on the
Washington journal it's our weekly your
money segment we'll be joined by IRS
National Taxpayer Advocate Nina Olson to
talk about the 2017 tax season and take
your questions as Tax Day approaches you
can start calling in now and we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]